[Musique]
alors le livre s'appelle quand vos nuits
se morcelle est ce qu était amoureux
j'espère tout le monde
ils savent que quand on est amoureux les
nuits commencent à se morceler et
puisqu'on a introduit ce que je vais
lire ces trois chapitres et que je sais
qu'il ya même une femme peintre et
j'espère plusieurs dans la salle je lui
dédie ces trois chapitres le modèle
arrivé de paris à genève
votre futur modèle a pris un hôtel sur
la rive droite
le lendemain matin elle a traversé un
pont sur la rade admirer la blancheur de
deux signes convenait d'apporter de
sibérie à 9 heures précises
elle s'est présentée à l'adresse convenu
29 rue du rhône où une fois vous avez
fait de l'ordre l'attendiez avec
impatience ce n'était pas tous les jours
qu'une femme d'une telle classe vous
proposer de la peindre dans votre lettre
de réponse vous aviez fixé un tarif à la
journée n'aviez pas prévu de lui payer
le voyage
vous pensiez qu'elle avait des amis à
genève plus tard elle vous a confié
qu'elle n'était muc par une sorte de
curiosité et l'envié de changer d'air
son visage vous avez passé la matinée à
l'apprendre par coeur
une symétrie parfaite une bouche
simplement belle des pommettes
saillantes mais douce de jolis oreilles
vous l'aviez installé deux faces avec
une lumière latéral qui scrutait chacune
de ces rides minuscule entre les yeux
autour des lèvres
vous ne saviez pas encore que c'est
parti là allez ce creuset jour après
jour quand il vous faudrait pas dans les
étapes de son calvaire
elle n'a eu aucune peine à rester
immobile pendant trois heures
brusquement à la demande et je peux voir
comment vous m'avez arranger elle s'est
levée pour contempler son visage vous
aviez fait un ovale parfait communes
comme celui d'une princesse
du côté de ravel
elle n'a mais elle n'a émis aucun
commentaire mais dans un geste d'une
hardiesse extrême à déposer un baiser
sur votre jouet vous avez longuement
nettoyer vos pinceaux sans rien dire
elle vous souriez vous étiez à sa merci
ensuite allemand vous auriez su quoi
répondre en français
rien ne venait à la fin comme chez votre
plume aux log
vous avez demandé et et quand est ce
qu'on se revoie pendant plusieurs jours
la scène s'est répétée l'arrivée à 9h
prenait la pose sans bouger jusque vers
midi quand elle se levait soudain pour
un baiser sur votre joue gauche
vous en aviez déduit que c'était une
habitude parisienne sans aucun
engagement de sa part vous invitiez
ensuite à la brasserie universelle qui
donnait sur le rhône
à deux pas de là elle se montrait guère
en jouer avec une anecdote sur chacun de
vos confrères parisiens sont savoir vous
éblouissent et parfois une ombre triste
traversé son regard sans doute la faute
à son ancien mari à jour vous avez
décidé de faire un pas de plus le
portrait presque terminée avait besoin
d'un peu de repos vous l'avait invité à
déjeuner dans une brasserie plus chic le
commerce place du molard madame avez
vous dira le voir votre verre je
voudrais vous peindre nu sa réponse je
savais bien monsieur de l'air qu'on en
arriverait là si ça peut vous faire
plaisir
j'imagine qu'à ce moment là quand vous
avez compris à quel point la parisienne
vous tenez par le coeur vous êtes
peut-être racler la gorge où vous avez
rougis ou bien crispé vos orteils dans
vos chaussures
le soir de vol potage votre femme berthe
vous à regarder de travers mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a qui préoccupe
montpetit ferdinand et vous rien du tout
rien ma chérie chacun a terminé sa soupe
en silence le lendemain vous aviez prier
votre modèle de s'allonger nu sur le
ventre comme pour dormir
lestrade recouverte d'un drap bleu
mettait à hauteur de vos yeux la courbe
de son
dos de ses reins de ses fesses une ligne
convexe relié à une comptable puis de
nouveau complexe
vous l'avez peintes comme l'horizon du
jura au dessus du léman montagne
assoupli entouré deux fois de bleu le
ciel et le lac vous découvriez non
seulement encore jeune parfait et tout
un paysage
elle a posé sans bouger sans dire un mot
pendant trois heures vers midi vous
attendiez de sa part un baiser sur la
joue et s'était endormi même le bruit
métallique de la boîte refermer sur vos
pinceaux ne l'a pas réveillé vous vous
êtes approché d'elle pour remonter le
drap bleu comment beau comme on board un
enfant elle s'est tournée vers vous dans
un long bâillement culoz utile et vous
leur du baiser depuis ce moment là vous
vous êtes tutoyé par jeu elle continuer
de vous appeler monsieur blair comme
elle disait baudelaire
quand chez vous en dit aude leur un
autre chapitre lausanne après votre
réconciliation quand vous allez voir
valentine à lausanne vous tiriez les
rideaux pour assombrir le lit en plein
après midi
l'écart est ce que vous inventez y est
vous semblez 6,9 d'une intimité si osé
de personnes encore en a vécu
l'expérience vous murmure y est l'un à
l'autre des phrases estropiés dont vous
n'aviez aucune habitude vous aimiez la
forme que prenait la bouche de valentine
qui dans l'orgasme s'ouvrait en une
expression presque douloureuse celle que
vous retrouverez chez elle beaucoup plus
tard al'approche de sa mort
vous étiez fasciné par le voile qui
recouvrait ses pupilles on aurait dit
les yeux d'un nouveau né arrivant de
l'au delà
il vous fixez lointain à la fois tourné
vers le dedans et le dehors elle vous
voyait coucher sous l emprisonner par
ses jambes disait quelque chose à propos
de la beauté de vos corps emmêlés
vous ressentirez une espèce de stupeur
d'être allé si loin avec elle
ensuite quand vous marchez à ses côtés
dans les rues de lausanne où personne ne
vous connaissais vous ne parveniez pas à
vous détacher de cette béatitude
vous auriez voulu pouvoir dire à chaque
piéton que vous croisiez que cette femme
était votre maîtresse adorée qui pouvait
faire de vous de votre corps ce qu'elle
désirait vous estimiez que ce n'était
plus un secret que la terre entière
devrait profiter d'une si bonne nouvelle
qui pourra autant effacer toutes les
autres venus des champs de bataille où
des scènes de ménages
jamais vous ne retombe auriez de ce
nuage bleu ou valentine vous avez emmené
il n'y aurait que la mort est à cette
époque vous ne saviez pas encore quelle
roue des as apporte à la vôtre
traversant le parc qui vous mallette à
la gare voulu proposiez mille suite à
votre histoire même si nous vous n'aviez
entrepris que cela pendant 100 ans ou ne
seriez pas parvenu à bout de tous ces
projets vous envisagiez de lui montrer à
madrid
le prado où vous aviez passé de longues
heures à recopier velasquez à new york
le nouveau pont de brooklyn en australie
les peintures dans le sahara puis voulu
parliez des lacs au nom prometteur en
bateau à rames sur le baïkal en pirogue
sur le titicaca
ou alors une chevauchée sur un lac gelé
d'estonie autres projets nationaux cette
fois à lucerne le lever du soleil sur le
pilate à constance vers midi quand le
säntis c'est clair de bleus sur toutes
ses facettes ou encore le soir au pied
de la jungfrau sous un clair de lune
violacé ce que vous aviez déjà vu vous
vouliez qu'elle le voit ce qui vous
reste est à découvrir vous ne
l'imaginiez qu'avec elle
vous étiez entrés ensemble dans la
grande librairie rue de bourg avis a
demandé des guides de voyage sur
l'orient extrême
c'était votre dernière lubie fuir avec
quelle par le transsibérien à l'autre
bout de la planète
en sortant de là elle vous avez fait
remarquer que vous pourriez facilement
la rejoindre dans la maison que louait
pour un mois sur une plage de la manche
giacometti vous avez raconté pente avant
elle vous parlais d'etretat au nord du
havre au salon de l'abc que vous aviez
vu le rocher percé peint par monnet vous
craignez de ne pas être à la hauteur
l'océan disiez-vous c'est trop de vagues
pour moi restons en aux vagues l'aide de
nos lacs chez l'italien près de la gare
dans une rue de traverse
vous avez commandé des raviolis aux
cèpes une bouteille de chianti juste
avant le départ du train sur le quai où
elle vous accompagner pour un dernier
baiser
vous lui aviez demandé un crayon vous
aviez votre carnet de croquis teulier a
fixé cet après midi avec elle vous
entendiez dessiner son regard extasié
ses pupilles dilatées qui vous avait
paru le comble de l'abandon pas de
crayon
tant pis le trap art et madame aude
l'air vous attendez à la gare de genève
le voyage aurait dû vous permettre de
reprendre vos esprits
il n'avait fait que les échauffez vous
écoutiez votre épouse d'une oreille
distraite les courses qu'elle avait fait
les rendez-vous pris pour le lendemain
soir un dîner en ville chez à bourgeois
qui voulaient de vous le portrait de sa
femme ou compriment entier la vôtre de
s'occuper si bien de votre vie
domestique
vous cherchez à être aimable puisqu'elle
n'était coupable de rien c'était déjà
presque blessant bourrel de vous
entendre dire non non j'ai pas vu le
temps qu'il faisait à lausanne et un
troisième chapitre s'appelle la gaieté
la parisienne vous avez interdit de
faire le rabat-joie par des propos sur
le temps qui passe et tout ce qui
pourrait un jour troubler le sourire des
amants elle voulait entre vous la gaieté
perpétuelle elle était celle que vous
aviez pas quand femme joyeuse
quand vous tête se rapprocher sur
l'oreiller elle plongeait ses yeux au
fond des vôtres et les commissure de ses
lèvres s'étirait remontait avec tant de
bonheur que vous ne pouviez qu'imiter ce
large sourire de gaieté puis vos bouches
se trouvait vous ne la retrouve y est
pas assez souvent occupé par votre
travail d'atelier les commandes vous
obligations sociales auprès de madame
aude l'air
valentino ci avait ses horaires
l'enseignement du dessin des voyages à
paris pour régler ses affaires
j'ignore si vous aimiez ces séparations
vous aviez fini par vous en faire une
raison vous un jour n'a été fixée par
d'autres que vous il vous fallait
prendre de vrais rendez-vous
même quand valentine poser pour vous il
lui arrivait de se dérober
pourtant après deux heures vous aviez
sculpter son corps nu vous brûliez de
passer dans l'alcôve de votre atelier
comme faisait vos collègues avec leurs
modèles valentine elle se rhabiller
fièrement si tu me veux ce sera chez moi
rue chaponnière je te reçoit volontiers
mais ce soir là vous étiez retenu par
une séance de la société des peintres
que vous présidiez l' avantage de cette
situation si je puis dire vous n'avez
jamais été saturé par sa présence vous
ne saurez pas l'ennui d'une rencontre
qui se prolonge
quand on a l'impression de s'être tout
dit d'avoir fait le tour et qu'on ne
voudrait se consacrer à autre chose vous
avez eu la chance de la rareté plus tard
une fois déclarée la maladie de
valentine vous passiez de longues heures
à son chevet vous saviez que le temps
vous est compté
non pas la petite durée journalière mais
le temps de vie lucide et qu'en ce temps
de grâce a pris fin quand elle n'a plus
bougé au fond de son lit
vous avez compris que vos nuits commune
mais intermittente ne se rejoindraient
ne restait que vos lettres échangées les
portraits que vous aviez fait d'elle
valentine avait raison de dire que dans
l'amour vous n'aviez d'âge ni l'un ni
l'autre et plus tard elle écarté la
question doit rire mais les évidences
demeurait vous ne feriez pas un couple
chacun donnait à l'autre de l'élan pour
sa vie quotidienne
une journée sans insigne d'elle et vous
étiez perdu guettant pour le lendemain
une visite impromptue à votre atelier un
modèle dans votre boîte aux lettres vous
demandiez à la femme de ménage de
descendre deux étages dès que vous
pensiez que le facteur était passé
madame aude l'air faisait mine de ne pas
comprendre
voyons ferdinand le courrier peut
attendre quand savait-elle cette
bourgeoise parvenu avec qui vous étiez
marié depuis tant d'années qui avait
posé pour vous mais jamais nue vous
aviez été pris quelques tonnes madame
aude l'air puis de moins en moins au fur
et à mesure qu'elle jouait son rôle
d'épousé sans enfant soucieuse de la
promotion de son mari ma grand-mère qui
l'a croisera plus tard dans la bonne
société genevoise me dira depuis que
monsieur auclair n'y est plus sa femme a
mis sa palette de peinture sur son
visage et quand la femme de ménage vous
apporter enfin la lettre de valentine
vous aviez ce comportement infantile qui
consiste à donner un baiser à l'
enveloppe avant de l'ouvrir gamineries
monsieur de l'air tant d'histoires pour
trois lignes que la parisienne tracé de
son écriture régulière presque scolaire
commençant par mon cher ferdinand qui se
terminant par je t'envoie de chaux et
tendre baiser
tout ça pour une anecdotes de sa vie
parisienne un souci de voyageuses
malassise une tendre pensée déguisé sous
une formule de politesse
il arrivait que ces lettres soit grave
elle disait qu avant de vous connaître
elle n'avait que peu de considération
pour les femmes qui avait une liaison
durable avec un homme beaucoup plus âgé
qu'elle
elle y voyait un signe de leur
immaturité de leur manque d'indépendance
une forme de
nation elle croyait que les hommes
aiment et les femmes plus jeunes par
vanité elle vous l'avez dit que vous
aviez commencé à lui faire la cour elle
avait dû réviser son jugement se rendre
compte de sa fragilité
vous aviez mis valentine sur un
piédestal peut être même un nuage voyant
monsieur auclair
après tant de femmes dans roulis temps
de chair nue recopier sur vos carnets
vos cahiers vos toiles ou séduisit vos
modèles mais aviv au principe au premier
garde d'éviter de vous trouverez père
d'un enfant dont vous pourriez être
grand père et maintenant il vous semble
que cette belle théorie ne vous a servi
qu'à attendre le jour vous rencontreriez
valentine cinq ans plus tard elle était
enceinte de paulette une guerre des
sambre in an dès vos journées
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]